Napoleon Dynamite was one of the most
unlikely hits of 2004 or any other year
really directed by 25 year-old Jared
Hess and starring a bunch of mostly
unknowns the quirky indie comedy was
difficult to categorize and against all
odds it grossed 44 million dollars
against the $400,000 budget so why won't
Hollywood make a Napoleon Dynamite
sequel uh-huh through busy hunting
Wolverines Napoleon Dynamite led to a
brief but fruitful period for star Jon
Heder he starred in a string of comedies
that included just like heavens the
Benchwarmers and blades of glory he
Duras in switched gears putting his
distinctive cadence to use as a voice
actor
oh he's racked up more than a dozen
credits for work on animated movies TV
cartoons and video games also a major
time slug fajita the man of a whole mess
of kids and while director Jarrod has
conned him to find images' applaud for
his own films he's still a director in
demand for other false projects he found
a few movies written by people other
than himself or his wife by the 2016
comedy masterminds and is slated to
direct the next long-awaited entry in
Jackie Chan's comedic shanghai trilogy
studios only one directors with skills
even still jarrod and jerusalem
continued to make one-of-a-kind movies
in their own style and flavor but they
just don't put butts in seats among
their efforts to luchador comedy natural
ebrary the fantasy fiction send-up
gentleman broncos and to the caper
comedy Don Verdean the directors have a
unique vision but they've had a hard
time attracting sizable audiences case
in point
gentlemen Broncos grossed just one
hundred and thirteen thousand dollars
which is about three times as much as
Don Verdean bought in and that's despite
both films having the comedy star power
fan favorite Sam Rockwell and Jemaine
Clement
the director doesn't flip and feel like
it Napoleon Dynamite is a classic
example of lightning in a bottle which
nobody understands better than Jared has
so he doesn't even really want to try
making a sequel in 2010 he told star
poster because the movie was conceived
as a one-time deal
a sequel wouldn't work saying when
sequels are an afterthought they usually
end up being but but when they were
originally intended to have multiple
films made up of the same story I think
it works in other words what are you
gonna do boy all right
you look at what the cartoon bombed
eight years after its auspicious
big-screen debut
Napoleon Dynamite did get a sequel of
sorts an animated TV series six episodes
run on Fox in the spring of 2012 and the
entire main cast reprised their original
roles the show finished a twenty eleven
to twelve season at number 103 in the
ratings after which it was quietly
canceled he goes Veridian napoleon lives
on audiences were able to pay another
unofficial visit to Napoleon Dynamite's
universe courtesy of an ad campaign that
adds shortly after the film's theatrical
run in Jesus of your the Utah State Fair
didn't have sweet rides like the
Scrambler Rocco plane
the octopus Jon Heder and F Ramirez
surprised that characters a few more
times in a series of TV spots promoting
the 2005 Utah State Fair also making a
cameo delicious tub that kinda looks
pretty good too trans villa and it
should look good I think my butt off
never has a fictional character love the
potato nuggets as much as Napoleon the
movie is so connected with tater top
site in 2016
Burger King recruited Heder and Ramirez
to star in a commercial for the chains
latest offering cheesy tub it's too late
Napoleon Dynamite is pretty much a high
school movie and following the film's
characters of a old tackle college and
marriage just doesn't seem like it would
be a very rewarding project and if all
of the characters are still somehow
living in the same small town that never
escaped the late 80s wondering ever
closer to death well the audience has
already seen how they behave in that
vibe
there's just not a lot more to say and
watching Napoleon slowly lose his
trademark cloud of hair to old age just
seems the present at least we'll always
have the original thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]